emmanuel dupuy président de l'institut
prospective et sécurité en europe
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous ce
soir sur rtl france on vient d'entendre
dans ce sujet l'inquiétude des afghans
des femmes notamment qui redoutent le
retour des talibans on évoque leur
emprise grandissante dans le pays qu'est
ce que ça signifie réellement et ce
qu'ils ont les moyens aujourd'hui de
revenir au pouvoir
mais je dirais autrement ils n'ont
jamais quitté le pouvoir on estime que
près de 30 à 40 % du territoire et
charge au gouvernement central et ce
malgré la présence numériquement moindre
que au moment où les troupes américaines
étaient les plus nombreuses c'est en
l'occurrence intime il sur les 150
milles ce trouble étrangères présentes
en afghanistan entre la période 2010 et
on estime que les talibans restent entre
60000 et 80000 et on estime de toute
manière contrairement peut-être à la
manière dont le reportage était imprécis
présenté que inéluctablement il
reviendra au pouvoir puisque l'objectif
même des négociations qui se sont
déroulées avec les américains le 14
février de l'année dernière et un petit
peu plus tardivement avec le gouverneur
afghan est précisément qu'il revienne
entre guillemets politiquement néanmoins
la vraie question c'est est-ce que les
talibans d'aujourd'hui sont les mêmes
que ceux qu'on avait chassé en 2001 de
nombreux témoignages eux-mêmes disent
que de toute façon ils ne changeront pas
grand-chose à leur motivation
pourquoi le ferait-il du reste puisque
la négociation américaine leur offre sur
un plateau ce qui n'aurait pas pu
espérer obtenir militairement dire
autrement si les américains étaient
restés plus longtemps si la coalition
internationale s'était étoffée puisque
il n'y avait il n'ya plus comme vous le
reportage met en scène parfaitement dans
le cadre de l'opération otanienne résolu
de supporte plus que le fils 600
militaires donc 2500 à 3500 américain la
situation serait tout autre les talibans
crient victoire mais les talibans aussi
estime qu' il n'aurait jamais pu défaire
les américains militairement par contre
diplomatiquement et politiquement c'est
une autre affaire
est ce que les autorités afghanes sont
capables de résister seul face aux
insurgés
alors les forces armées afghanes sont
bien équipées elles sont maintenant bien
entraîné depuis maintenant une présence
internationale depuis 20 ans 1 il y a
près de 350000 forces de sécurité
afghanes
elles sont maintenant la capacité d'agir
évidemment ils agissent avec un soutien
logistique un soutien en matière de
renseignement notamment fourni par les
36 pays encore présent 36 pays dans le
cadre de l'opération dans encore
présents l'afghanistan et bien
évidemment les forces américaines
néanmoins les forces américaines ne
disparaîtront pas totalement de la
région
ils quitteront sans doute l'afghanistan
le principe étant de quitter
l'afghanistan
le téléphone tard devant quitter avec
amy semble 11 septembre 2021 mais ils ne
quitteront pas la région ça et donc ils
pourront agir si de besoin néanmoins
pour répondre à votre question de
manière beaucoup plus peur prosaïque les
forces afghanes lors est théoriquement
pas besoin de combattre puisque les
talibans ferait partie du gouvernement
pourquoi faudrait-il qu'ils combattent
une identité qui est accepté ou serait
acceptable selon les termes d'un accord
de paix la question la vraie question
c'est pas tellement
est ce que les forces de sécurité
afghanes pourraient empêcher les
talibans de revenir au pouvoir
et est ce que on n'est pas à l'aune
d'une guerre civile où un certain nombre
de représentants communautaires un
certain nombre de deux provinces
n'accepteront de toute façon pas le
retour des talibans on a la certitude
déjà depuis plusieurs mois que les
tadjik les ouzbeks les lézards a
notamment dans la région du wardak sont
en train de se réarmer et les maintenant
combattre non seulement les talibans
mais comme moi est également les forces
armées mais ce que président afghan a
raison de croire que le retrait
américain signifie qu effectivement les
talibans n'ont plus de raisons de
continuer à se battre
le président afghan a pas beaucoup de
choix 1 le secrétaire d'état en tenez
plus qu'elle a été assez clair en lutte
activement l'ordre de procéder à de
nouvelles élections alors que ces
élections ce sont les dernières
élections qu'ils sont
encore valable se sont déroulés l'année
dernière il a concédé à l'organisation
d'élections initiative que de toute
façon des talibans ont rejeté partir du
principe qu'il n'accepte pas le principe
d'une élection pour jauger leur retour
au pouvoir le président sharif ali n'a
aucun pouvoir
deux tiers du financement de du budget
afghan vient de l'extérieur c'est pas
seulement la question n'est pas
seulement lié au fonctionnement et au
financement des forces armées mais bien
au financement de l'état en tant que tel
les états unis dépensent cas
annuellement depuis que les troupes
occidentales sont quasiment toutes
parties 4 milliards de dollars et les
états unis ont payé un très lourd tribut
c'est la raison pour laquelle les
américains entendent gérer ce retrait
seul alors qu'il n'engage pas seulement
des troupes américaines il ya un près de
1000 soldats allemands près de 800
soldats italiens près de 700 soldats
britanniques mais les américains c'est
vraiment payé un très lourd tribut 2300
de leur solde à son bord 20 mille
blessés et ils ont dépensé près de 1
trillion mille milliards de dollars pour
essayer de stabiliser l'afghanistan
et pourtant l'afghanistan après plus de
20 ans mais toujours pas stabilisée
merci beaucoup pour votre regard
emmanuel dupuis je rappelle que c'était
un président de l'institut prospective
et sécurité en europe